Plus this week and this week we have a
special guest talking to us about the
AdMob SDK and but as you can see
something happened to anchor last week
um I'm not sure what happened he's not
with us today um but we have Tony with
us so Tony hey tell me i'm from hong
kong also developer advocate guys and we
have fresh our special guest joining us
today from monkey i believe yes hey i'm
raja from mount view i work as part as
the AdMob developer relations team cool
um I guess we can get started straight
away so um the Google AdMob ads SDK rush
take it from here sure so like I said
I'm part of the animal developer
relations team and I'm going to be
talking about the AdMob ads SDK today to
you guys next slide so I'll let's start
at the very beginning you just r in your
Android application now there's lots of
apps out there and sometimes they're
really hard to distinguish so how do you
pull users into your app one option is
that you can promote yourself by setting
up an ad campaign through a network to
advertise on tens of thousands of apps
these are the kinds of ads that you
typically see that take users right into
the play right into an applications play
store page where they can download the
app from there next slide so now let's
say that you've already got users and
they're using your application of course
one of the ways to monetize here is to
make your application of paid app but
the reality is that people really love
free apps advertising is a great option
here it can give you the ongoing revenue
stream that continuously comes in it's
also generally easy to implement no
matter how big your application is next
slide and this is where add mahal comes
it so let's start with the basics add
mobs a mobile app advertising network
that allows you to monetize your app and
allows advertisers to promote their
content how does this work advertisers
provide AdMob ads to run on its mobile
network admin relies on you the mobile
app developer to serve these ads in your
apps we
also recently announced AdWords
advertisers which are in the millions
can actually buy inventory from magma
this means that if you're an AdMob app
developer you've also got access to
these millions of advertisers so on the
left side of this picture you can also
see that us app developers can actually
become advertisers and promote your app
with mobile advertising next slide so
let's touch on the promotion aspect of
this for a bit so promoting with AdMob
lets you set up an ad campaign and
advertise on a plethora of apps you can
target based on different factors such
as device country platform or even
demographics such as gender age and
other things there's a number of
benefits doing this if you're
advertising gets you into the top 50 in
the App Store for example you're likely
to enjoy even more organic downloads
from people browsing the store cross
promotion is another way to get users
into your apps once you build a loyal
user base for one of your apps that
you've built you can actually leverage
this to promote another app your loyal
users will probably be more willing to
try out other apps as well how's that
specifically allow you to promote any
other app in your portfolio so this can
even be used to actually promote apps
beyond mobile so that's a definite thing
to think about as well next slide so now
back to the monetizing side monetizing
with AdMob is super easy all you need to
do is include the Google AdMob ads SDK
in your app create a banner view within
your application and load ads into it
ads from Google advertisers are then
displayed in your app and users click on
the adds that they like you get paid
every time a user clicks on ads in your
application an ad based business model
is a continuing stream of revenue coming
in to your app it skills as you will so
as your app gets bigger and you get more
users you have much more opportunities
to monetize next slide so let's break
down how the numbers work here so using
the AdMob SDK you're actually going to
make request to add mobs server for ads
in this particular example let's say
that your application makes 120,000
requests an AdMob typically can't fill
all of those
a number of factors playing here
inventory is one of them if we say that
eighty-three percent of those requests
gets filled you've got a hundred
thousand impressions an ad impression is
actually reported whenever an individual
ad is displayed in your app CTR or the
click-through rate is a ratio that shows
how often people who see your ad end up
clicking on it of course the higher CTR
is a good thing it's a good indication
of whether users find your ads helpful
and relevant in this example we've got a
CTR 1.5% when you factor in our
impressions when you factor in our
impressions this turns into fifteen
hundred klicks AdMob actually pays out
on a cost per click basis so your app
earns money based on the number of
actual clicks that are received exactly
how much you make per click it actually
vary substantially based on a number of
factors these include the type of app
your user base and general market
conditions we actually operate in hand
marketplace so the price of a click at
any given moment is determined by the
bids that are being placed by the
advertisers if we assume a CPC of ten
cents here for the sake of simplicity
it's really easy to calculate what your
revenue is going to be in the end next
slide so we tried to make getting
started with the AdMob android sdk as
easy as possible you can check out our
step-by-step tutorials as well as
documentation on
developers.google.com/live got any
issues with it I've me and the
aggressive developer relations team are
always willing to hear you out you'll
also need to sign up for a publisher
count on admiral calm AdMob calm is the
front end where you'll be controlling
things related to actually serving ads
within your application to get up and
going with the Android SDK you've got to
release kapali against Android
three-on-two but we've got support all
the way down to one doll five next slide
so the first step to getting up and
going is setting up your manifest you've
got to declare an addict tivity in your
manifest um we've bolted out the two
things that you've got to do there at
the bottom you see you declaring the
addict tivity you also gotta make sure
to declare the internet and access
network state permissions of course
because ad requests are going to be are
going to require these we also give you
the ability to handle your own config
changes so the ad won't be
refreshed when some of the config
changes occur next slide so let's look
at the code to create your ad view this
also is very simple you've got to import
the necessary classes from the comrades
package here we're declaring an ad view
instance and you you're going to have to
specify an ad unit ID there this is the
ad unit ID that you get from AdMob calm
when you sign up for a publisher account
mmm you can actually add the view into
the UI and load it with and hat by
giving it an add request object when
you're developing though we ask you to
make sure that you're in test mode to
avoid being disabled for clicking on
your own hands next slide so one of the
things to keep in mind is that before
being passed to add view download ad
which we saw in the previous slide an
add request can be customized to allow
Google to actually better target those
that so you can use the ad test device
method during development to void
generated false false impressions by
requesting test ads for specific devices
or your head you later you can add any
devices that you've got there um logcat
should actually help you out in this it
should print the devices md5 hash tidy
for convenience you can also specify
location and demographic targeting
information however out of respect for
user privacy we do ask that you only
specify the location and demographic
targeting info if it's already being
used in your application next slide you
can also track ad lifecycle events like
request failures or click throughs by
implementing addlistener in an object
you pass you pass through to the add new
set addlistener this interface can be
implemented by either your activity or
any other object these allow you to do
certain things in your application if an
ad is received or an add request fails
you can also stop or pause things in
your app if an ad click is going to take
a user order the application into the
Play Store for example next slide so an
important thing we try to encourage
users to do is to use the right ad
format for the device that their users
are on we saw that the ad view
constructor earlier takes a parameter
which
to specify the type of format that you
want in order code examples case earlier
it was at sized up manner so notice how
on the example on the Left we've
requested an ad that is way too big for
this screen this is actually our medium
rectangle format we recommend that
people show this Olli on tablets if it's
not a great user experience when an ad
is taking up fifty percent of your
screen real estate on the other hand on
the right side we've got a custom format
that looks way too small you can't
actually even tell what it is so at that
point the user experience is suffering
again the format we typically recommend
for phones are 320 x 50 banners which
are which is the one we've got in the
middle there next slide so the most
popular banner size that we have is the
323 or 20 x 50 banner which you can use
on both phones and tablets it's mainly
used on applications develop from phones
though for tablet ops we do offer some
larger sizes such as the 320 x 50 medium
rectangle which we saw in the previous
slide and a 728 x 90 leaderboard however
the smart banner format is a new format
we introduced back in april these span
the entire width of the screen and have
variable height depending on the screen
size next slide so these smart banner ad
units which we introduced in the six
goals SDK I believe actually render
screen white banner ads across any
screen size for different devices in
different orientations so what these do
is they help deal with the increasing
screen fragmentation across different
devices by detecting the width of the
phone in its current orientation and
making the ad view that same size this
also solve another problem of requesting
the right type of format for the screen
mode so this is whether the screen is in
landscape or whether it's in portrait
and requesting a smart banner ad is
super easy we've got a smart banner ad
size constant that you just pass through
to your constructor next slide
so we've also got some guidelines on
where your application should be placed
in your app in your actual app where
your ads should be placed in the actual
application I've outlined some bad
placements on this slide so we can start
with the one on the left actually
needless to say don't make your ads
transparent / cover touchable areas with
your ads that's generally a bad thing
the middle example deals with something
sort of similar ads shouldn't be placed
where users will randomly click or place
their fingers on the screen in this
example if you're playing this game
you're very likely to slip at a slip-up
and click that add a rodas another
another example of something like this
could be if you've got a children's app
for example where bubbles are randomly
appearing on the screen and you're
popping them you probably don't want ads
on a screen like that the example on the
right doesn't necessarily cover a
touchable area but it is very close to
the buttons so don't place the ads close
to or underneath the buttons or any
other object which users may
accidentally click on you don't want
users to click on the ads without
knowing essentially try not to put ads
anywhere where you may get erroneous
clicks ultimately it leads to a bad user
experience and bad reviews for your app
typically next slide so let's talk and
another important facet of admob ads are
the filters that we've got set up so the
filters tab provides a huge amount of
control over the ads that show up on
your inventory we've got URL text
category of language filters euro
filters pretty simple they prevent ads
linked to a specific URL or domain from
appearing in your app text filters
prevent ads containing or matching text
phrases from being shown on category and
site filters prevent certain categories
that's for being displayed an example
that this is you can prevent image ads
for being displayed which would prevent
any type of image boundaries from being
displayed in your app we you can also
enable age-appropriate ads so
age-appropriate ads are actually
disabled by default what enabling these
allows you to do is display
ads that are rated as age-appropriate so
not necessarily suitable for all
audiences examples of these are gambling
and personal ads AdMob actually doesn't
accept ads that promote any adult
products or services um for the language
filter you can print ads of certain
languages from being displayed on your
app although we do recommend that you
make sure that none of these languages
are relevant to your user base all right
just want to interrupt a little bit also
in general for our policy regarding ads
on end so I just want to add that on top
of arm so one thing we are developing
need to remember now is as it's really
part of the entire application
experience so the policy the content of
the ads is really part of the
application itself so so from if you use
other AdWords advertising network so
make sure you pay attention to that
because you may actually violate some
content policy on on the android phone
if you're using apps that is not comply
with our our general content policy no
def with those settings are definitely
no matter what ad network you're looking
at it's something that you should make
sure that you're reading very explicitly
oh yeah so you just going on we actually
usually tell advertisers to be as
permissive as possible using all these
filters just because this does maximize
the amount of ads that are available to
run on your inventory and ensures that
you're generating the highest revenue
potential that we can offer as an ad
network on next slide so similarly
there's some other things that you can
actually do to optimize your ad settings
you can also increase your fill rate by
taking advantage of google certified ad
networks inventory so with this option
set we will actually attempt to fill
your ad request with not only ads for an
AdMob which explicitly target mobile
apps but also adds from google certified
ad networks at general keyword targeted
ads so enabling these ads provide a
great opportunity to increase
your fill rate and your revenue no code
changes are actually needed here we
conduct a pretty thorough certification
process before we let any network in for
third-party ad serving but you have to
remember that at this time you can
actually apply any of your add filters
to these google certified network at
just something to keep on it's also
important to know that you need to set
your refresh rate at a pretty you need
to set your refresh rate at the right
amount um and add that refreshes way too
often can definitely adversely affect
your CTR it doesn't give users a chance
to view the ad and decide if they're
interested in clicking it we usually
recommend that users that they refresh
rate between 45 and 60 seconds this can
all be managed within the ad mobs front
end in faced actually next slide so
AdMob is great but what if you want to
use a different ad network to multiple
Emacs amaizing fill rate add your
revenue we actually offered a free
mediation service which developer to use
to integrate multiple add nodes into
their application and make server-side
decisions on how to distribute the
request among those ad networks so ad
network eCPM actually usually very over
time that's what you're seeing that
graphite there ec PM's are just your
effective cost per thousand impressions
how much money you're making um when
you're using mediation you can actually
fine tune your mediation configuration
so that the ad network that is
performing the best gets the most
requests if you keep track of how each
of your networks are performing a tune
your request distribution accordingly
you're essentially optimizing your eCPM
to make the most money so keep in mind
that some ad networks do perform better
in certain markets AdMob mediation
provides the ability to enter regional
and country level settings that override
the default add that word distribution
settings next slide getting set it up
with mediation is super easy just add
your mediation ID which you can get an
ad mops front end and you're all set you
don't need any additional coding and you
can even send special targeting
parameters to specific ad network
adapters remember though that if you are
added
a party networks to mediation you'll
also need to include their SDKs and
adapters in your projects next slide
yeah then give me yeah fantastic that
looks looks really easy to get started
with a lot of opportunities out there
for for developers fantastic thank you
very much you're welcome um so Tony do
we have anything on the moderator for
this week yeah so let me let me take a
quick look yes I think we got our two
questions on moderator so uh so let me
with the first one out the first one is
from are you rock so what are the
benefits of using AdMob over I add or
millennial media so I get rush so I add
a millenia media our computing ad
networks and they differ in a number of
different ways filler adcp mcpc are just
some of these factors what I'd actually
recommend is that you can get set up
with all of these networks using
mediation and see what works for best
best for you under specific conditions
and that way you can best optimize your
own revenue oh oh so the neck the next
question is from Simon or the question
was I want to use a leaf bolt and at
Mach how can I do it so mediation is I
guess the answer here again I'm so with
mediation we actually do have out of box
support for a number of ad networks
which means we've got adapters for them
if there's an ad network that you don't
we don't have specific support for you
can actually write something called a
custom of that so what custom events
allow you to do is in a great custom
code into the mediation flow so that
they behave like any other ad network
that participates in mediation we've got
box for this up on developers.google.com
feel free to check about thank you rock
I think that's all we have on moderator
ambulance yeah fantastic thank you very
much so I think that that's all we have
for this week so thank you very much our
special guest from a triage thank you
Tony and yep as
next time cool tastes like ass wipe